Katie Taylor's symptoms before menopause
were so severe she worried she might
have early onset dementia but hormone
patches changed everything it was like a
dark folk had just lifted I had I hadn't
realized I hadn't laughed in four years
and suddenly my husband and my kids sort
of said look I've got my wife back I've
got my mum back I just felt Joy the
cognition was back I could concentrate I
just felt back to my old self more women
in the UK have begun taking hormone
replacement therapy leading to recent
shortages
clinical trials investigating a
potential link to alzheimer's present a
confusing picture it's fair to say
a new study from Denmark found that
compared with women who never used HRT
those who did had a 24 higher risk of an
eventual dementia diagnosis the risk
increased with the duration of treatment
reaching 74 for people who took HRT for
more than 12 years but the Danish study
contradicts other research which
suggests HRT may help prevent
Alzheimer's disease we need more
research to understand the risk factors
of dementia to understand what's driving
and the diseases that cause dementia to
understand how we can prevent or reduce
risk over the long term the NHS says the
benefits of hormone replacement therapy
usually outweigh the risks women
shouldn't come off their medication just
because of this new research I've had
loads of emails this morning I've had
people messaging me in our Facebook
group on our Instagram Channel worried
and saying well should I come off my HRT
or I'm not going to start got it now and
and and it's really awful actually
while more studies are needed the
confusion around these treatments can be
seriously distressing especially when
the stakes are so high for so many women
Becky cultural Sky News North London